(bright chiming music)
Dr. Conner is back,
and we're gonna turn our ascension
to Pulmonary Number Two, and we're gonna discuss asthma.
Thank you, Shawn.
Thank you, David.
So we're back with the discussion
of obstructive illnesses.
So now we're going to talk about asthma.
What's new in asthma?
Everything is new.
So the last time they gave us asthma guidelines,
do y'all remember?
2007.
So we've been waiting with bated breath for all these years.
17 years later, they finally gave us updates.
Now, so the NIH in 2020 updated the asthma guidelines.
So the expert panel focused group,
the same people
work with the World Health Organization and created GINA.
How many are familiar with GINA guidelines?
GINA are the same people at GOLD.
So the Global Obstructive Lung Disease group
that we talked about last time, it's the same with GINA.
GINA stands for Global Initiative for Asthma.
So it's the NIH people in conjunction
with the World Health Organization.
They both gave us new updates in 2020
and everything has changed except for diagnosis.
So I underline management under guidelines
because diagnosis has not changed.
So that part at least is easy.
So let's dive in.
Asthma physiology, of course, lots of inflammation here.
Way back in the day, we used to think this was a disease
of bronchoconstriction.
Now we know how much inflammation plays a role.
So keep that in mind with your asthma patients.
That's why, you know, David was joking about the steroids.
With respiratory medicine,
particularly obstructive illnesses,
steroids are almost always the right answer.
So your asthma symptoms are intermittent and recurrent.
They come and go, you know, in between exacerbations
the patient may be normal,
asymptomatic and abnormal lung function.
Of course, cough and wheezing,
dyspnea are common symptoms,
exacerbations and triggers,
which can be seasonal or perennial.
Common asthma triggers upper respiratory infections,
environmental insults,
medications, and other illnesses.
Again, don't forget about GERD.
Okay, our first question.
So we have a 12-year-old who's brought into your office
for a well visit.
Their parents report, they have nighttime cough
and wheezing for the past several months.
They deny chest pain and are otherwise healthy
and up-to-date on immunizations,
physical exam is unremarkable.
Which one of the following tests would be most
appropriate at this time?
So we have a 12-year-old with several months
of nighttime cough and wheezing.
Would we do A allergy testing,
B, a chest x-ray, C fractional exhaled nitric oxide,
also known as pheno or D spirometry?
Good, 92% of you got the correct answer spirometry.
So that's how we diagnosed obstructive illnesses
like asthma and COPD.
Spirometry is the way to go here.
Now I will say maybe if the patient was two years old,
I might think of, you know,
an inhaled foreign body or something,
but a 12-year-old it would be different.
Alright, so how do we make the diagnosis of asthma?
Well, we talk to the patient.
We verify a history of variable
and intermittent respiratory symptoms.
We document that airflow obstruction with spirometry,
which we use in order to make the diagnosis
to assess the level of severity
based on impairment and risk.
That hasn't changed since 2007,
and to exclude alternate causes.
Our friends at choosing wisely say we should not diagnose
or manage asthma without spirometry.
And I would agree.
Unless the patient's under five,
in which case you're gonna go ahead and treat
because they can't do the spirometry.
So this is the recommended test.
You may want to do other specific tests
based on each individual patient.
That could include allergy testing.
If you're unsure of the diagnosis,
you might do a pheno level.
Pheno is, how many of are familiar with pheno levels?
So this is an evolving trend in respiratory
medicine to look for inflammation.
So if you're not sure, you could do a pheno level.
And higher levels are consistent with elevated inflammation.
Next question.
Same case.
When performing a spirometry on your 12-year-old
wheezing patient,
after the administration of a bronchodilator,
what percentage of airway reversibility
and change in FEV1 is consistent
with the diagnosis of asthma?
Here we go again with these number questions.
I hate them.
Is it A, 12% in 500 milliliters?
Is it B, 25% in 200 milliliters?
Is it C, 12% in 200 milliliters
or D, 18% and 100 milliliters?
Now let me see, can I sleuth this one out?
Well, maybe.
A and C both have 12%,
B and C both have 200 milliliters.
What do they have in common?
C, which is the right answer?
Woo, we got lucky.
Do try to memorize these numbers.
However, because you never know
how the boards are gonna ask them.
They may not give you something as easy as I did.
So your asthma diagnosis with spirometry,
you're gonna see an FEV1 decrease
to less than 80% of predicted.
And you're gonna get reversibility
after a bronchodilator by 12% and 200 milliliters.
Those are the numbers to memorize for the boards.
Increase by 12% and 200 ml.
Here's your spirometric values.
Here's your tracing that I showed you before with COPD,
that FEV1 because of obstruction
is gonna be hard to get out.
And then there's your flow volume curve.
Your differential.
You know, anything else that can cause wheezing.
What do they teach us in medical school?
All that wheezes is not asthma, right?
Lots of other things can happen here.
In younger kids, it could be upper respiratory infections.
Upper respiratory cough syndrome.
That's that throat clearing from sinus drainage.
It could be an inhaled foreign body.
It could certainly be gastroesophageal reflux disease.
Older kids.
Think about Alpha-1 antitrypsin deficiency,
if they're a young adult.
COPD, if they're older,
cardiac failure emboli.
And again, don't forget about tuberculosis.
Asthma diagnosis in other contexts.
Occupational asthma is a big deal.
Pregnant women should all be evaluated.
The elderly, they often go undiagnosed.
You may think that it's only you know their CHF or ischemia,
but maybe some of their symptoms are coming from COPD.
Smokers and ex-smokers we'll talk about the, well,
we already, no, we will talk about the asthma
COPD overlap syndrome.
Athletes have exercise induced bronchoconstriction.
And then these patients with persistent cough,
which we'll talk about this afternoon.
You know they don't have asthma,
they don't have COPD, but they're coughing.
Is it sinus drainage down?
Is it reflex up?
It's an interesting discussion.
This hasn't changed either.
The level of severity.
This is the treatment that's required
to control their symptoms.
So it's retro, it's assessed retroactively
after several months of symptom control.
That's how you determine the severity level.
The problem here is the whole mild
asthma category is tricky.
GINA, the Global Initiative for Asthma,
has recommended we stop using the term mild asthma.
Because you label someone with mild asthma,
but 30 to 37% of adults
with acute asthma had symptoms less than weekly
in the previous three months.
So just because a patient's mild
doesn't mean they can't have a severe exacerbation.
Control is a different word that means different things
to the patient as it does to me.
Is your asthma controlled?
Yeah, I'm great.
I saw one of these patients just a few weeks ago,
came in for a routine visit.
How's your asthma?
Great.
You feel like it's controlled?
Yes.
How often are you using your inhaler?
Patient was only taking a short acting bronchodilator.
Oh, six or eight times a day.
A day.
And you think that's controlled?
Well yes, because I use the inhaler.
My symptoms improve, I feel fine.
Sure, I guess I'm controlled.
You're not controlled at all.
So that's why of course
we have these validated questionnaires.
In COPD, it's the COPD assessment test.
In asthma, it's the asthma control test
for patients 12 and older.
So you should be using these.
Now we want to assess their severity
and their control within both domains
of impairment and also risk.
Impairment, I like to think of is how bad are they?
Risk, how bad can they get?
This is the NIH asthma severity classification, which again,
like I said, has not changed since 2007.
You've got intermittent asthma
and then you've got persistent asthma,
which is mild, moderate, or severe.
We all remember this, right?
So it's based on symptoms.
Intermittent asthma,
they have symptoms less than twice a week.
Mild persistent more than twice a week.
Moderate persistent daily.
Severe continual.
Probably won't be asked that question on the board
because this is so old and it hasn't changed since 2007.
Here again, we talk about the risk of mild asthma.
GINA no longer recommends that we use this term at all.
Okay, so we have different categories of asthma medications.
We've got our controller therapy
and that's traditionally been an inhaled corticosteroid
that they might use once or twice a day
to keep their symptoms at bay.
And then you've got the reliever therapy,
which is the short-acting albuterol beta-agonist, right?
Oh, well, you know, which inhaler do you use for what?
I don't know.
I got the gray one and I got the red one.
Well, which do you use?
You know, I don't know doc, I get confused.
So this is problematic.
You know, sometimes the patients don't know
which inhaler to use.
Is this my controller or my reliever therapy?
Not every patient is savvy enough to remember
what their short-acting beta-agonist is,
versus their inhaled corticosteroid
with throughout a long-acting beta-agonist.
They don't know.
That's why these guidelines have changed.
So next question.
Same patient, same case.
Your patient with asthma had been managed
with a daily inhaled corticosteroid along
with a short acting beta agonist.
So they had the two inhalers, two separate inhalers.
On a routine follow-up visit,
their asthma control test score was 15,
indicating that they were uncontrolled.
After assessing for proper inhaler adherence and technique,
the next best step in management would be,
which one of the following.
The boards love to ask these questions
where they say the next best thing.
Now that doesn't mean that any of these could be bad,
they want you to pick the best one.
So in this case, what should we do?
A add a long-acting muscarinic antagonist,
B, add salmeterol,
C, change their therapy to low-dose
inhaled corticosteroid with formoterol daily, and prn,
or D, continue present management.
I don't think D'S the right answer
'cause the patient is, you know, worsening symptoms.
So it can't be continue present management.
So we're either gonna add a LAMA, we're gonna add a LABA,
or we're gonna change their therapy to this daily
and prn combination.
What do we like?
Good, y'all maybe played the long answer card.
I don't know, but you got the right answer,
which is correct.
So these are the new asthma guidelines, which are amazing.
So inhaled corticosteroids have always been the preferred
controller therapy for many years.
In patients with asthma,
they reduce hospitalizations and death.
They can be used intermittently
or along with long-acting beta agonists.
And of course we now have the triple inhalers now too.
There's a couple of those.
Inhaled short-acting beta-agonist.
Again, like I said, this has been the mainstay
of therapy for years.
Patients think they get better, you know,
so we're just treating this bronchoconstriction
as it happens.
The problem is we're missing the anti-inflammatory.
And asthma always has an inflammatory component,
not just bronchoconstriction.
So this monotherapy
with a short-acting beta-agonist
in the GINA guidelines is out.
And the NIH guidelines, they still use them.
Okay, so we also know that frequent use
of a short-acting beta-agonist can have
worse clinical outcomes.
The boards love to ask you
if a patient is using one canister or more
a month of their albuterol,
that increases their risk of death.
So they love to ask that question.
And as I mentioned, GINA no longer recommends
short-acting beta-agonist as monotherapy at any age.
You've got long-acting beta-agonists,
but this is contraindicated as monotherapy and asthma.
Remember I mentioned this.
It's okay in COPD, it's not okay in asthma.
You have to combine a long-acting beta-agonist
with a steroid.
Now,
what's new about these guidelines is
what's called SMART therapy.
How many of our familiar with these
new SMART therapy guidelines?
Not enough of you.
So this is replacing everything.
So we now have one inhaler
that serves as both your maintenance
and your reliever therapy.
I don't have to deal with the gray one and the red one.
I've got one inhaler now.
And that inhaler is an inhaled corticosteroid
with a formoterol.
It's called SMART therapy that stands for
Single Maintenance and Reliever Therapy.
So any of these patients at like a persistent asthma level,
you would give them this inhaler,
and you would say use it as needed.
If you're feeling fine, you don't need it.
If your asthma starts acting up,
you might need it once or twice a day.
If you get worse, use it four times a day as needed.
And then of course if you need it more than that,
you probably should come in and see me.
But this allows the patient, gives them the freedom
and the ability to respond to their symptoms
with one single inhaler.
I love this, especially for adolescent.
How many of us teach adolescent medicine?
How many of us have?
Come on now.
How many of you see teenagers in your practice?
Yes.
Good, same.
So trying to get an adolescent or a teenager
to schedule something twice a day, good luck.
So this is a wonderful addition to our armamentarium,
to change them from a bid inhaled corticosteroid
and a prn, short-acting beta-agonist
to the one single inhaler.
Love these guidelines.
Alright, long-acting muscarinic
and have antagonist play less of a role
in asthma as they do in COPD.
Cromolyn is out because it's takes too long.
You gotta do it four times a day.
Leukotriene modifiers were in for many years,
they've fallen out of favor because of the neuropsych issues
and the new black box warning.
So singular not what it was.
Now here are the guidelines.
This is the NIH guidelines, not GINA.
They're age related.
So you've got the zero to four age, you start with a prn,
short-acting beta-agonist.
If they get a respiratory tract infection,
you add an inhaled corticosteroid,
and then you step up as needed.
Now in this age group, any patient beyond at step three
or higher probably should be seen pulmonology.
If you have pediatric pulmonologists available
where you live.
And you step up and you add, you increase the amount
and the strength of the steroid as needed.
At five to 11, it's similar.
But at step three we have the SMART therapy option
with the inhaled corticosteroid and formoterol.
The real star of the show here with SMART therapy
is the formoterol molecule.
Formoterol is unique among long-acting beta-agonists,
because of its very rapid onset
of action under five minutes.
So the only problem here with the SMART therapy is
that it's not an FDA approved indication.
So we're still having insurance companies kick back
'cause they don't wanna pay for it.
So you step up as needed.
12 and up, same situation, put 'em on the SMART therapy.
Don't forget about subcutaneous in immunotherapy.
And at five or six you might want to consider the biologics.
So it's pretty self-explanatory.
So with intermittent asthma,
you can get away within inhaled short-acting beta-agonist
per the NIH guidelines.
Persistent asthma needs an inhaled corticosteroid
with a short-acting beta-agonist.
And anyone at moderate to severe needs the SMART therapy.
Step up or down as needed, refer to pulmonology as needed.
Here's some options for severe asthma.
I don't think they'll ask you these on the boards.
Our friends at Choosing Wisely say
that we should avoid stepping up asthma therapy,
adding new drugs
or going to a higher dose without first
assessing adherence, appropriateness of device,
and technique with current asthma medications.
So it's very important if they ask you on the boards,
always assess their inhaler technique
before making any other changes.
This is a very important slide.
They love to ask these on the boards.
Risk factors for poor outcomes with asthma.
High use of the short-acting beta-agonist,
more than one canister a month.
As I mentioned, they love that question on the boards.
Exposure to cigarette smoking, yes,
and maybe other inflammatory markers.
But especially the overusing, the short-acting beta-agonist.
Now your monitoring,
you bring 'em back, see how they're doing.
Follow up visits should be every couple of months.
If a patient's really well-controlled and stable,
I usually like to see 'em every six months.
I'm from Detroit.
So with our allergy season, I like to see patients
in the spring and the fall.
That's typically when my patients get into trouble.
So every six months is fine.
You assess their technique.
Your measurements of control are the same as the severity.
Those are the asthma control test questionnaires.
And then you go up or down as needed.
With the SMART therapy, you give the patient the permission
to kind of do some of this on their own.
And that's the day-to-day adjustment that they can do.
There's also short-term step up where you increase
the frequency of the strength of the inhaled corticosteroid
and then a sustained follow up as well.
Stepping down.
If they're doing very well,
you could consider stepping down their treatment.
The Symbicort, which is the brand name
for the budesonide and formoderol,
it comes in two strengths.
It comes in 80 milligrams or 160.
So you could, if they were on 160,
you could step 'em down to the 80,
if you were doing SMART therapy.
Be sure that the time is appropriate.
You don't want them traveling, you don't want them pregnant,
you don't want them in their
present state upper respiratory infection.
And you approach each one of these steps
as a therapeutic trial.
You know what, we're gonna try this.
We're gonna see you back in a couple months
and see how you did.
Schedule a follow up visit.
Peak flow meters, we don't have data,
but the expert panel loves them.
Along with asthma action plans.
So you should be giving your patients written asthma action
plans that are individualized.
They tell the patient how to recognize
and respond to their symptoms.
They provide advice on what to do.
And this is based their personal peak flow best.
Okay, so asthma action plans are endorsed.
They have been proven to reduce morbidity
and decrease hospitalizations.
Next question, question four, same case.
Your patients' asthma had been well controlled
until an abrupt onset of nasal congestion, clear drainage,
body aches, and worsening cough of five days duration.
They're now wheezing and requiring use
of their short-acting beta-agonist
every three to four hours.
Exam reveals a slightly anxious patient
in no acute distress.
Respiration of 18, SaO2 of 97%,
temp of 99.4, no retractions.
Auscultation shows mild inspiratory
and marked expiratory wheezes.
In addition to continued frequent use
of their short-acting beta-agonist,
which one of the following would be
the next best step in the management of their problem?
A, admission to the hospital. B, oral antibiotics.
C, oral corticosteroids, or D oxygen.
Remember what I told you about
respiratory medicine and what?
Steroids, yeah.
So of course oral corticosteroids are
what we need to prescribe here, good.
GINA prefers that we use the term flare-up
as opposed to exacerbation.
When we're having a discussion, you know,
amongst our colleagues, we can say exacerbation.
We know what that means.
But you should probably try to use the term flare-up
when you're talking to your patient.
So this is a worsening of their symptoms.
And of course the management can go anywhere
from your written action plan to come into the office.
You know, maybe you need some steroids,
maybe you need some antibiotics, I don't know.
And then all the way to the emergency care
and hospitalization if they're more severe.
Technically this is a decreased peak flow.
Less than 70% of predicted normal.
Oftentimes it's just the symptom of I'm no longer responding
to my beta-agonist.
Pay attention to these slides.
Historical risk factors for death with asthma.
History of severe exacerbations requiring intubation prior
admission to the unit.
ER visit in the last year.
Current use or recent withdrawal from systemic steroids.
Not currently using an inhaled corticosteroid.
Overusing their short-acting beta-agonist.
Those are the biggest historical risk factors.
Physical risk factors.
The biggest one here is absence of wheezing.
A patient in a severe exacerbation,
they're not moving any air at all.
So you don't hear any wheezing.
That's an ominous finding.
Exacerbation management.
You're gonna put 'em on oxygen as needed.
You're gonna do short-acting beta-agonist.
You can do the metered dose inhaler or the nebulizer.
Current data suggests the MDI is equal to the nebulizer.
Continuous nebs are superior to intermittent,
definitely put them on steroids, oral or IV.
There is some role for inhaled ipratropium,
and then the others are no longer used.
Antibiotics.
Maybe in clinical practice you might,
for the purposes of the boards,
I would say usually yes in COPD, but no in asthma.
'Cause the boards don't like antibiotics.
Exacerbation management, the degree of severity.
Mild, moderate, severe, life-threatening,
that's self-explanatory.
You have to follow up in the office
with all of these patients
to be sure their symptoms have normalized.
So a patient has an asthma exacerbation.
I like to think of this as an opportunity.
You know, what has gone wrong?
Well, you know, I was fine until I got
that upper respiratory infection.
Okay, well you, maybe you can't do anything about that.
You know, I ran out of my inhaler.
My insurance company won't cover it.
So I stopped using it.
There's all sorts of reasons here
that it could explain an exacerbation.
So it's a great opportunity.
Next question, same case.
Your patient's now 18 years old
and their asthma severity level is presently intermittent,
requiring only a short-acting beta-agonist occasionally.
They recently started training for a marathon,
however, and they're now complaining of worsening cough
and decreased perform when they run.
Requiring daily use of their short-acting beta-agonist.
Which one of the following would be the next best step
in their treatment regimen?
A, add a daily inhaled low-dose corticosteroid.
B, increase the frequency of short-acting beta-agonist use.
C, lifestyle modifications like decreasing their exercise
frequency, warming up until the symptoms improve.
Or D, substitute a long-acting beta-agonist
prior to exercise.
So this is of course exercise induced bronchoconstriction.
That's the new term.
We don't say exercise induced asthma anymore.
They're no longer responding
to the short-acting beta-agonist.
What could we use next in respiratory medicine
with an obstructive disease?
I don't know.
I think maybe it's the steroid.
Yes, and the majority of you agreed.
Good.
Those of you who did the long-acting beta-agonist,
that used to be in the old guidelines.
But remember, monotherapy with a long-acting beta-agonist
and asthma type illnesses is out.
Okay.
All right, so exercise induced bronchoconstriction.
This is thought to be due to cold dry air.
You diagnose it with spirometry.
You do a before and an after.
So before you exercise, exercise,
and then repeat the spirometry.
And you'll see a decrease in the FEV1 of 10% or more.
What's interesting about EIB is it occurs
in 90% of asthmatics,
but up to 20% of athletes
who don't have asthma will get
exercise induced bronchoconstriction.
And some newer studies are suggesting the pheno levels.
Short-acting beta-agonists are preferred prior to exercise.
If they don't improve,
you put them on an inhaled corticosteroid
or you could use the SMART therapy.
Okay, good warmup.
Yes, yes, yes.
The asthma COPD overlap.
There's a confluence here in patients who smoke.
The take home message, I would say
is you want to treat according to the predominant symptom.
So if they are asthma predominant, if they have a lot of,
you know, mucus production and cough,
you're probably gonna put them on a inhaled corticosteroid.
If they have more COPD predominant where it's more dyspnea,
you're gonna use combination bronchodilators.
And of course, like I said,
there's two triple therapy inhalers out now
and a third one coming.
Asthma during pregnancies, a highly variable.
A third of the time they worsen.
A third of the time they improve.
Sometimes they remain stable.
But the portion symptom control
and exacerbations are a risk both
to the mother and the fetus.
So we have to take asthma during pregnancy very seriously.
We want to see them often.
For the purposes of the boards.
Albuterol is your preferred SABA,
and budesonide is your preferred inhaled corticosteroid.
Monthly monitoring is recommended.
It is also recommended not to step up your step down your,
I'm sorry, don't step down the therapy during pregnancy.
And you definitely don't stop the inhaled corticosteroid.
Don't forget to treat other illnesses that may be at play,
including allergies and reflux.
And always remember that inadequate control
of a pregnant patient's asthma poses a far greater risk
to the fetus than any medication.
So do not be afraid
to use medications in your pregnant patients with asthma.
Alright, thank you very much.
Thank you very much Dr. Conner.
(bright chiming music)